♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
From Boston tonight,
we have a nightmare story
of random crime
and violent death.
SPEAKER: October 23rd, 1989.
A 9-1-1 call comes in
to state police dispatch.
There's been a murder
at Mission Projects.
(SIRENS WAIL)
Husband and wife
who was pregnant.
The Stuart case
is the ultimate truth serum
in the city of Boston.
Boston was stunned by the murder
of a pregnant woman.
REPORTER: Her husband, Charles,
was still hospitalized.
SPEAKER 2: When crimes happen
in certain parts of Boston...
REPORTER 2: And forced his way
into their car.
REPORTER 3: They were shot
by a Black man.
We all fit the description.
Cities are naturally segregated.
Boston takes it to an extreme.
Let us go to our neighborhoods
where our kids are safe.
The '70s were a very
tumultuous time in Boston.
SPEAKER 3: There was persistent
racial violence.
SPEAKER 4: You had heard
this legend of Boston
as a birthplace of democracy.
But then we also have
another history, as well.
Send them back to Roxbury.
That people will just call this
the most racist city in America.
(POLICE RADIO CHATTER)
(SIRENS WAILING)
SPEAKER 5: I instructed
the police commissioner
to be as aggressive
as they ever have been before.
They took my house all apart.
SPEAKER 6: They drove me down
to South Boston.
I was a-- a scared kid.
"Own free will,"
that's not true.
SPEAKER 7: When you're police,
your job is to investigate
all aspects.
REPORTER 4: A murder that
grabbed the nation's attention
takes a bizarre turn.
This story didn't add up.
SPEAKER 8: We'd been waiting
for this case to be uncorked.
SPEAKER 4: When you start
connecting all of these dots,
it creates a really
ugly puzzle.
SPEAKER 2: We knew what was
about to happen.
This is going to end badly
for everybody.
♪ (TENSE OUTRO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪